our next guest she is a successful
philanthropist best-selling author and
she is a self-made businesswoman with a
capital b
bethenny frankel started out with her
lifestyle brand called skinny girl
making her signature margarita so over
the past 13 years she has expanded her
brand into wine to food to shape wearing
accessories sunglasses
you name it she has done it the
powerhouse and powerhouse is a word here
is also the author of one two three four
five new york times best-selling uh
books drop the microphone miss bethany
her latest is called business is
personal the truth about what it takes
to be successful while staying true to
yourself now we should point out that
this is her first business focus book
bethany frankel joins us live in studio
good to see you bethany frankel thank
you for having me no i'm not starting a
business but if i was i've already read
this book so i have some idea about what
to do but anybody anybody out there
who's thinking about starting a business
you've got some great tips i love the
title business is personal because we
all know that saying it's not personal
it's business and that normally happens
when you're getting um something bad has
happened i know what you wanted to say
you're going to say again that's morning
tv but you say business is personal why
because it's time away from your
families it's sacrifices you make it's
passion drive hard work and
determination you cannot be very
successful at business if you don't
really put your heart and soul into it
and your heart and soul is entirely
personal but you say you were you are
not successful because of what you sell
but how you sell it's about the
connection any brand any person who's
successful in their office anyone rising
to the top even being good uh you know
in your school pta it's about you
connecting with others listening
communicating they're buying into you
you're becoming successful then whatever
you decide to write sell with integrity
that will also be successful because
it's a reflection of who you are as a
person there are so many good little
nuggets i'll just rattle off too and you
can decide which you want to do you
don't make decisions based on money but
on ideas
you do female empowerment not by not by
talking but by showing you said don't
talk do well so many women say as a
woman i'm afraid or what uh
opportunities have you not had or what
struggles and i know you've faced this
as a woman of color
if you just sort of think about that and
you get mired in that just like getting
mired into business plan you'll get
stuck and you'll think about what you
can't do no one ever told me to think
about being a woman i just sort of walk
through and get dirty and break some
eggs and make mistakes but learn from it
and become stronger and figure out i am
not traditionally a business person i'm
just an idea person who works hard and
executes so you learn like case law by
trial and error and that's how anybody
can be successful particularly now
because the snow globe has been shaken
it's non-traditional now you can figure
it out in so many different ways
speaking of shaking things up snl
creator lorne michaels told you you have
to make an exit in order to make an
entrance he did i listen that's a good
thing i crowdsource i listen to things
that people say and you make your own
recipes so yes i was at dinner with
laura michaels and he said about
somebody who was on his show you have to
make an exit to make an entrance and
that was how i sort of thought of when i
left reality television and left a lot
of money on the table with millions on
the table millions on the table and
would figure out what the plan was next
i just didn't feel it was right in my
gut so i moved was there any fear in
leaving that money on the table leaving
that opportunity you know recognition of
being on a reality franchise yeah no
because you feel if you're being true to
yourself and you're taking those calm
times to really be honest
you know what's right and dollar signs
cannot dictate a decision skinny girl
it's been 100 million business for you
uh but you've also had a couple of
failures what do you mean by protecting
your realm the realm for any business
person entrepreneur at any level is what
am i doing what am i representing
standing for what's my culture and
sticking to it and it's very difficult
you get offered different things the
shiny objects come you want to go take
the path of least resistance you've got
to stick to what it is you can shift but
overall if you protect the realm
you will layer it you don't become
successful overnight it takes years and
years and years
and then you just have a fully baked
brand or success that's built on
integrity which is what you do when no
one's looking but most of us don't know
you we first got to know you from the
housewives franchise where does that sit
with you today uh because it certainly
has played a role in all of your success
it's evolved too yeah well it showed me
as a person who certainly it showed me
as a person who was afraid and certainly
not successful by any standard
relationship-wise money-wise i just was
someone trying to figure it out being
honest about it so that whole experience
represented me being honest about my
flaws and working the mirror reflection
almost right and so that still holds
true today it's just a different package
now so you can be in any circumstance i
mean you literally could be at any job
relationships jobs bethany says in her
book she's aggressive and unfiltered but
she says she gets stuff done and that
you do bethany frankel cheering you on
continued success yeah thank you can i
say that you are
but the way that you handled this whole
experience today with me you are a boss
you are thorough
that's for sure can i talk about your
book bethany's book business is personal
goes on sale